(UPBEAT ROCK MUSIC)
♪ RIDING ON ANY WAVE ♪
♪ THAT IS THE LUCK YOU CRAVE ♪
♪ THEY DON'T BELIEVE IT NOW ♪
♪ THEY JUST THINK IT'S STUPID ♪
♪ SO GOT ANYTHING ♪
♪ ANYONE COULD'VE DONE ♪
♪ WHO WOULD'VE CARED
AT ALL, NOT YOU ♪
♪ ANOTHER HEART HAS
MADE THE TRADE ♪
♪ FORGET IT, FORGET
IT, FORGET IT ♪
♪ I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW A HEART IS A SPADE ♪
♪ BUT SOMEHOW THE VITAL
CONNECTION IS MADE ♪
(UPBEAT ROCK MUSIC)
♪ RIDING ON ANYTHING ♪
♪ ANYTHING'S GOOD ENOUGH ♪
♪ WHO WOULD'VE THOUGHT
IT OF SOMEONE LIKE YOU ♪
♪ JUST AS THEY
BROUGHT ME 'ROUND ♪
♪ NOW THAT THEY
BROUGHT YOU DOWN ♪
♪ ROUNDABOUT AND ROUNDABOUT ♪
♪ WHO WANTS A LIFE ANYWAY ♪
♪ ANOTHER HEART HAS
MADE THE GRADE ♪
♪ FORGET IT, FORGET
IT, FORGET IT ♪
♪ I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
THE LAST CARD IS PLAYED ♪
♪ BUT SOMEHOW THE VITAL
CONNECTION IS MADE ♪
(UPBEAT ROCK MUSIC)